[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
NELSON BOYCE: I want
to welcome all of you
all to Google and to
the YouTube space.
I can't imagine
that anybody doesn't
know who these people are.
We've got Chris Webber,
Lisa Leslie, Nate Robinson.
[APPLAUSE]
Four-time Olympian, five-time
All-Star, three-time Slam Dunk
champion.
The list of
accomplishments goes on--
LISA LESLIE: Three?
NELSON BOYCE: --and on.
LISA LESLIE: Nice going.
NELSON BOYCE:
Nate's the only one
to have ever actually done that.
CHRIS WEBBER: And
stand up, Nate.
[LAUGHTER]
This is the guy that won the
3-point league dunk contest.
No, stand up.
And this is the guy that--
that's a bad man right there.
[APPLAUSE]
LISA LESLIE: Three times--
NELSON BOYCE: We're going to
talk about a number of things
today.
I'm excited to be here.
I'm Nelson Boyce, by the way.
I work here at Google.
And I'm thrilled
to have the best
seat in the house with these
lovely folks up here today.
So everybody knows, I
think, that "Uncle Drew,"
in theaters
nationwide on Friday,
of which all of these
folks are stars.
It's going to be exciting.
I saw the movie last night.
It was incredible
and very, very funny.
And all of you did your thing.
I will tell you that, for sure.
Just to give you
all a little bit
of the premise of
the movie, there's
a gentleman who, under
unfortunate circumstances,
is unable to field his
team at the Rucker.
So for those of
you who don't know,
Rucker is a playground
tournament up in Harlem
that happens every year.
It's incredible.
A number of historic players
have come out of that.
But there's one
player in particular,
played by Kyrie Irving,
who has the opportunity
to go ahead and field a team
from the past, if you will,
to come back and play the
Rucker once again in hopes
of winning the championship.
And that's when all these
folks come into play.
It's based on the character
Uncle Drew some of you
may know based on a
Pepsi-created digital episodic
that was very popular
and ultimately became
a movie with our
friends at Lionsgate.
So to that end, this
question is for everyone.
How did this come together?
How did it go from an
episodic to a movie?
And did your agents
reach out to you,
or did you guys
actually audition?
How did it work?
NATE ROBINSON: Well, Lisa
definitely auditioned.
I'm going to let her
tell you the story.
It's awesome.
Her story is pretty
cool than mine.
But I just bugged Kyrie
until he told me yes.
[LAUGHTER]
Every game that we had,
I played against him,
he's at the free throw
line, and I'm like,
"'Uncle Drew,' what's up?
Can I be down?"
I was just bugging
him every time.
We checking in the game--
"Bro, I'm serious.
What's up?"
Then he hit me on
Twitter, was like,
"Were you serious about
being in the commercial?"
And I was like, yeah, of course.
And that's how I'm here.
NELSON BOYCE: The
origin [INAUDIBLE]..
Nice.
Lisa, what about you?
LISA LESLIE: For me, my
agent called and said
that they were shooting
for "Uncle Drew,"
and there was a part
for Betty Lou, who
plays the wife of Preacher-- and
Chris Webber plays Preacher--
and he hadn't had the
part at that time.
But I was going to be the wife.
And Betty Lou, obviously, has
to get buckets at some point.
NELSON BOYCE: That's right.
That's right.
LISA LESLIE: So I wasn't
concerned about that.
But I'm like, OK, so tell
me more about Betty Lou.
Betty Lou has to be in her 70s.
And I'm like, OK, got it.
So I get off the phone with my
agent, and I go in my closet,
and I go shopping a little bit.
And I came out, and
I was like, babe--
I was telling my
husband, who I call babe.
I said, babe, in order
for me get this part,
I'm going to have to go
in dressed as Betty Lou.
They have to believe
I can do this.
So I went in, full--
NELSON BOYCE: Oh, full on.
NATE ROBINSON: Yes.
Dressed the part.
LISA LESLIE: I was Betty
Lou when I walked into--
when I got off the elevator,
I was bent over and hunching.
"Hey, baby, how you all doing?"
I came in talking to everybody,
"Oh, yeah, Betty Lou is here,
and can you just let the
producer know I showed up,
'cause they said they
needed me to come.
Fool, please!
You better move."
[LAUGHTER]
NICK ROBINSON: Perfect.
LISA LESLIE: So I
just walked in being
Betty Lou, full everything,
with my Bible toting.
NATE ROBINSON: Job on the spot.
Job on the spot.
LISA LESLIE: An
hour later, my agent
called and said I got the part.
NELSON BOYCE: She is a fiery
character in the movie,
I will tell you that.
And what about you, Chris?
CHRIS WEBBER: And she
didn't tell you about her
thigh-stockings that she--
and the old lady pearls.
LISA LESLIE: The nylons,
they got to stop short.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah,
yeah, exactly.
LISA LESLIE: Put
a run on the side.
CHRIS WEBBER: Exactly.
I got a call, and I think that
the part was already cast.
And I knew that they
were part of it.
And of course I'm
a big fan of Nate.
And I know Nate and
Lisa is probably,
out of all the
athletes, has probably
been acting the
longest, and modeling,
all the stuff she did.
And so I've been in the
church my whole life--
NELSON BOYCE: And I was
going to ask you about that.
Because you did it.
You got down with it.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah, yeah.
My father was a
deacon in the church.
My mom was a choir director.
So I'm one of those kids would
get whoopings in the church
and come back and have to sit
up there and all that stuff.
And so it wasn't a
better role for me
than to be a basketball player--
which, I played basketball.
And then to emulate some of
the passes I knew growing up.
So I tried to take them,
along with some great movies,
like all the other
guys that have done it.
And hopefully it's-- when
you said a good movie,
I'm thinking that the audience,
they're like, yeah, right.
Because that's, I think--
we all knew it had the potential
to be super corny, super
bad, terrible.
LISA LESLIE: That was the
scariest part, by the way.
Did you want to know
the answer to that?
I was like, what did
I get myself into?
I try to keep my
brand real on-point.
And this could be
a true downfall.
CHRIS WEBBER: This
could take you down.
Yeah.
Yeah, but they got it
turned out all right.
The script was funny.
And when I read the script,
I was laughing out loud.
And I was like, you know what?
This Is going to be funny.
So you've seen the
movie the other night,
it was good that
it came through.
NELSON BOYCE: Oh, for sure.
I had the benefit of
being at the premiere.
And you brought a little
extra something to it.
I will tell you that.
I'm not going to give
it away, but there
is a scene in the church
that you all will remember.
NATE ROBINSON: Yeah, yeah.
Forever.
NELSON BOYCE: It's pretty good.
LISA LESLIE: Amen.
[LAUGHTER]
NELSON BOYCE: Amen.
Amen to that.
So a little bit more
about the movie.
I think the
underlying foundation
about what's there is the
pure love for basketball.
Can you share with the
audience and the folks
here today the moment that you
fell in love with the game?
LISA LESLIE: Well, I didn't
fall in love with the game
initially.
I was not a sporty girl.
I was really more into, like,
I don't want to get hurt.
I have amazing girl
cousins who were tough.
They were running,
they're kicking butt,
they're playing
football with the boys.
I was on the side like,
do you guys need water?
[LAUGHTER]
I was just not
really into sports.
NELSON BOYCE: I
can't belive that.
LISA LESLIE: Really.
No, this is a true story.
I was the cry baby
of the family.
I wasn't really tough.
But basketball, for
me, really found me.
I think it was more my destiny.
Because I started playing
in the seventh grade.
And I only played
basketball because there
was a girl who was in
the ninth grade who
was so popular, I'm like,
why does everybody know her?
And her name was Shay, and she
was on the basketball team.
And I thought, I
want to be popular.
So I'm going to play basketball.
But I had one rule-- if
I fall down, I'm done.
Thank god I did not fall down.
Our team went 7 and 0.
I won my first trophy,
smaller than this cup, no lie.
And that trophy, I was
like, you get a trophy?
I fell in love with basketball
once I got the trophy.
NELSON BOYCE: You've had
a few more since then.
LISA LESLIE: Yeah,
it was a trophy.
CHRIS WEBBER: A few
gold medals, too.
LISA LESLIE: Yeah.
The fact that you win
something, that was it.
And I really fell
in love with it.
And I put in so much work.
And I realized that it
would open up doors.
I could get a
scholarship to college.
My mom was not going to be able
to afford a Division I school.
And so then it started to
make sense, having good grades
and playing basketball.
I was really into
education, very nerdy.
I know.
Didn't look like it.
No, I'm just kidding.
I was really into school.
I really loved school.
But basketball just
opened so many doors
that I had to stick with it.
NELSON BOYCE: Beautiful.
Beautiful.
And that is your
championship ring, is it not?
What's that?
LISA LESLIE: This one is not.
NATE ROBINSON: Probably MVP.
LISA LESLIE: This one is my Top
20 WNBA Players of All Time.
NELSON BOYCE: Mm-hmm.
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
NATE ROBINSON: Bam.
LISA LESLIE: Isn't she lovely?
NELSON BOYCE: And a Hall
of Famer, by the way.
And a Hall of Famer,
on top of all that.
LISA LESLIE: They sent
me one that's cute.
The other ones are too bulky.
NELSON BOYCE: Nate,
what about you?
When did you fall in love?
Do you remember the moment?
NATE ROBINSON: For
me, I was brainwashed
at a young age, man,
watching Michael Jordan.
As a kid, that's all you saw
on TV, for the most part,
was watching guys like that.
That helped me
believe that there
is a way for me, a
little guy from Seattle,
to make it to the league.
And I'm a different animal.
I was just hungry.
As a young kid, 10
years old, I just
knew what I wanted
to do since that day.
And after that, I just
never looked back.
NELSON BOYCE: Yeah,
you still hungry.
You still hungry.
NATE ROBINSON:
Yeah, still hungry.
NELSON BOYCE: I told you, we
could use you on the Knicks.
I'm a diehard fan,
so we could use--
and what about you, Chris?
CHRIS WEBBER: He was killing
when he was on the Knicks, too.
NELSON BOYCE: Yes, sir.
CHRIS WEBBER: He
was doing his thing.
Well, first of all, Nate
is being real humble,
too, because he could
have gone pro in football.
That's why I wanted
him to stand up.
Because I think basketball shows
you it's not about your size,
but it's about your heart.
You look at AI, small athlete,
one of the nicest killers
I've ever known in the game.
And this guy's one of the
best athletes the league
has ever seen.
He's won three dunk
contests, a great DB,
and could have gone
into the league.
So he definitely was
a different animal.
For me, I wanted
to play football.
That's what I wanted to
be, a football player.
And I fell in love playing
sports in the street.
We had a neighborhood
that had a bunch of kids.
So in the summertime, it was on.
Two square running
bases, playing games.
And so I just fell
in love with sports.
I just fell in love with
friends and competition,
that camaraderie.
And I've been this
height since ninth grade,
so my body told me,
you better do this.
Don't go over there
in football, they're
going to break your legs.
[LAUGHTER]
So it came natural.
But I always wanted
to be an athlete.
NELSON BOYCE: That's awesome.
And didn't you try out
for Seattle, the Seahawks?
NATE ROBINSON: I tried out
for the Seahawks, yeah.
They gave me a little--
I wouldn't call it a full--
NELSON BOYCE: Semi-combine?
NATE ROBINSON: It was a semi--
yeah, it was pretty cool.
I got to work out in front
of Pete Carroll, the owners.
And Russell Wilson was there.
That was pretty cool.
He gave me a football,
signed the football for me.
So yeah.
I'm more of a fan
a lot of the time.
I get geeked out seeing
different athletes.
It's pretty cool.
NELSON BOYCE: Good stuff.
Speaking of players, as the
movie came together, were there
any other NBA or WNBA
players that tried to join
the cast that didn't
work out, or would you
have liked to have
seen in the movie?
LISA LESLIE: You mean
as in take our spots?
NELSON BOYCE: No.
[LAUGHTER]
Not in taking your spots.
LISA LESLIE: Nah, I'm good.
No, there weren't
any other players.
We played against other players.
But there weren't, other than--
I think Gordon was the only
other NBA player, right?
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah.
That was it.
NATE ROBINSON: That was it.
LISA LESLIE: Yeah, that was it.
NELSON BOYCE: And assuming
there's a sequel--
and I hope there would
be one-- who would
you want to see join
you all in the movie?
CHRIS WEBBER: Well, Kevin Durant
was at the premiere last night.
NELSON BOYCE: I did see
him last night, yeah.
CHRIS WEBBER: And I told
him after the movie--
because before, I was like,
I know what you're thinking.
I was like, it's not
going to be corny.
Trust me.
He was like, all right then.
After, he was like,
"Oh, man, I love it.
I'm in part 2."
I was like, all right,
don't tell anybody.
I'll be your agent.
I'll negotiate--
[LAUGHTER]
--that for you.
But it would be fun
to have Kevin Durant.
To dress up-- we're all 70
years old plus in this movie.
So to dress up and
have some older guys,
it'll be fun, definitely.
But I think our crew,
the fact that we
were all athletes, the fact that
we're used to being vulnerable,
we're used to working hard,
we're used to asking for help--
that really made it a
collaborative effort,
the fact we didn't want
to let each other down.
I didn't want to
let Betty Lou down.
Boots didn't want
to let us down.
And so it was really unique.
They say when you retire, you
miss the locker room and not
the games.
And I think that's true.
And I got the locker
room with these guys.
And I feel sorry for our
director, Charles Stone,
because I'm sure it was
like a professor teaching
a kindergarten class.
Because we were having
fun every second.
NATE ROBINSON: For
the whole year.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WEBBER: Every second.
"All right, let's hurry
up, take the take."
And after that, he would
pull out a backpack
with music and all the
extras and be dancing.
NATE ROBINSON: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS WEBBER: He was
like, "Oh, no, slow down.
Stop."
But we had fun, definitely,
on set the whole time.
NELSON BOYCE: That's wonderful.
So you mentioned two things I
want to talk about a little bit
more.
So the makeup.
NATE ROBINSON: Oh, man.
NELSON BOYCE: Talk a
little bit about that.
It was full-on transformation
for all of you.
NATE ROBINSON: For the
first time, I called my mom.
I'm like, mom, I'm sorry
for making fun of you
for putting on makeup for hours.
It sucked.
Literally, it's sitting
there hours doing the makeup.
I'm like, man, so this is
what takes women so long.
Tell my girl, I feel you.
So it was tough.
It was difficult. Four
hours for my makeup,
because they had the cover all
the tattoos and stuff for me.
But it was still fun.
Once I got the four hours
out of the way and--
NELSON BOYCE: Four hours.
NATE ROBINSON: --I'm
in character, I'm like,
yeah, when do we start?
Yeah, so it was long for me.
NELSON BOYCE: Same
experience for--
LISA LESLIE: I think,
for Betty Lou--
yeah.
Women, we're a little bit
more accustomed to being
in the chair.
Not quite two and a
half to three hours.
So to get ready to
be Betty Lou and have
the prosthetics put on--
I try to think of it
as being in the spa.
[LAUGHTER]
NELSON BOYCE: You're
trying to relax through it?
LISA LESLIE: And
calm down and relax.
NATE ROBINSON:
That's a long spa.
NELSON BOYCE: That's a long spa.
LISA LESLIE: And then
I would put my headsets
on, the wireless ones, and
take it behind my neck.
And then I watched "Insecure"
and "Game of Thrones."
So this was last August.
So I had to finish
up the season, right?
So I just watched that every
day until I had to have my eyes
shut.
And then I was good.
I think the hardest part
is probably taking it off.
NELSON BOYCE: Oh, really?
NATE ROBINSON: Well,
yeah, the wigs--
LISA LESLIE: Yeah, well,
because we had to wear wigs.
NATE ROBINSON: I did.
LISA LESLIE: We
all had wigs, also.
I'm like, listen,
edges are really
important in this lifestyle.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm like, listen-- because
they want to put glue.
I'm like, OK, listen.
This is a movie.
But I need you to just pin
this down and pin this down,
and Betty Lou will be fine.
But the take off is
a little strenuous
because they have to
basically exfoliate your face.
NELSON BOYCE: Oh, wow.
LISA LESLIE: Yeah,
and that's scrubbing.
And I'm like, listen,
we need to look good.
Chris had some little
bit of reactions.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah.
LISA LESLIE: Actually, I
think you had the biggest
struggle of everybody.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah,
it felt like I
was getting burned with
acid during the [INAUDIBLE]..
LISA LESLIE: His face was like--
CHRIS WEBBER: I'm trying to
act, I'm like, I'm burning,
and it really hurts.
And my neck is coming off.
But it was three hours.
And we weren't used
to the makeup chair.
LISA LESLIE: I had to switch
him to my face cream, actually.
NELSON BOYCE: And this
was an everyday process?
CHRIS WEBBER: And took some
beauty lessons from her.
LISA LESLIE: Yes.
NATE ROBINSON: Every single day.
CHRIS WEBBER: Every day, yeah.
LISA LESLIE: Yes.
I'm like, you guys
have to moisturize.
Boys, you need to moisturize.
CHRIS WEBBER: I didn't even
know what moisturizing--
LISA LESLIE: They didn't know.
They were like,
what does that mean?
We're like, when you leave here,
you need to put more cream on.
And I'd come back fresh
faced, because you've got to--
[LAUGHTER]
NELSON BOYCE: Right, right.
LISA LESLIE: And they're like,
you don't have any irritation?
I'm like, no, guys.
You have to moisturize.
It's so important for your life.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah,
yeah, for sure.
LISA LESLIE: Rodan
and Fields, guys.
Look me up on Instagram.
NELSON BOYCE: She's got her
green juice working here, too.
CHRIS WEBBER: Our makeup
coach, that's right.
NELSON BOYCE: So
that's her product.
CHRIS WEBBER: Our
healthy makeup coach.
NELSON BOYCE: Indeed.
LISA LESLIE: We had a
green juice every morning.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah, we did.
We did.
[LAUGHTER]
LISA LESLIE: Spinach,
kale, blueberries.
NATE ROBINSON: For skin.
CHRIS WEBBER: Lisa kept
us-- you know what?
Thanks for keeping us right.
LISA LESLIE: I got you guys.
I'm the mom.
NELSON BOYCE: And
you also mentioned
the fun that you all had
on set, and the dancing.
I'm not going to give
the whole thing away,
but there is a dance
battle in this movie.
And I just wanted to
get the real scoop.
So who's got the most skills?
CHRIS WEBBER: Nate and--
LISA LESLIE: Nate, by far.
CHRIS WEBBER: Nate--
LISA LESLIE: Nate.
And Kyrie.
CHRIS WEBBER: Nate and Kyrie.
NATE ROBINSON: See,
with me, I just
couldn't wait to start the day.
Like, man, can we hurry this up?
Like, this is my
thing, right here.
The music, the fun.
It was fun.
Who surprised me most
was Reggie Miller,
because he couldn't
dance a lick,
and he got out there, really
showed that he could do it.
LISA LESLIE: No,
Nate taught Reggie--
NATE ROBINSON: It was awesome.
LISA LESLIE: --how to dance.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah, you
taught him how to dance.
NATE ROBINSON: We were
literally practicing
throughout our lunch
times, because we
didn't have that much time.
NELSON BOYCE: Because he's
got to start the routine.
NATE ROBINSON: But
the funny thing
is, during lunch, we're
literally in our makeup.
We can't take our makeup off.
So we're literally
having conversations
like this with old people.
So it was funny.
I was telling C, I was
like, bro, this is funny.
You're guys are
telling an NBA story--
"Man, I remember when I
used to dunk on Shaq."
And I'm looking at him like,
he look like a real preacher.
[LAUGHTER]
A preacher out here, looking--
it was pretty cool, just
the whole dance scene,
and getting Reggie
ready to dance.
LISA LESLIE: Reggie
started with zero moves.
NATE ROBINSON: Because he
was nervous the whole time.
LISA LESLIE: Zero moves.
NATE ROBINSON: Like, bro,
just enjoy yourself, bro.
I said, you're in a mask.
LISA LESLIE: I'm like,
have you ever danced?
NATE ROBINSON: You're good.
Nobody even knows.
Just do your thing.
But he did a great job.
NELSON BOYCE: So you put
him through a clinic.
NATE ROBINSON: Yeah, yeah.
LISA LESLIE: Yes, daily.
NATE ROBINSON: I had
to get him right.
LISA LESLIE: I've got
to post those videos.
NATE ROBINSON: I had
to get him right.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah.
Reggie's ready to go to
weddings and stuff now.
Because before--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--he was socially
dancing awkward.
Like, you don't want-- he'd
probably hit you with the--
[LAUGHTER]
You know what I mean?
NELSON BOYCE: With
the sprinkler.
CHRIS WEBBER: Oh, he's terrible.
LISA LESLIE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS WEBBER: But now,
his back straightens.
NATE ROBINSON: Dancing
the whole time.
CHRIS WEBBER: Like,
want to dance?
Anybody at the party?
What?
Happy for Reg.
NELSON BOYCE: I love it.
LISA LESLIE: Nate's
dance class, 101.
NELSON BOYCE: Too funny.
In terms of anxiety--
and all of you have done
some level of acting, right?
First pro game or
first day on the set--
which one was more
nerve-wracking?
CHRIS WEBBER: Oh,
first pro game.
NATE ROBINSON:
Yeah, first for me.
LISA LESLIE: Yeah, first
pro game, for sure.
CHRIS WEBBER: At least
you get a second take,
and you can mess up.
But you're checking Hakeem
Olajuwon your first game,
you're going to get
embarrassed, period.
That's what it's going to be.
So yeah, I'd much rather do that
than a first game, any time.
NELSON BOYCE: I hear that.
I hear that.
So we'll pivot away from
the movie for a second
and talk a little bit more
about career and life stuff.
What was the most challenging
time in your career,
and how did you overcome it?
NATE ROBINSON: Man.
LISA LESLIE: Oh, wow.
Now he's just dug deep, huh?
NELSON BOYCE: I'm
going to keep going.
LISA LESLIE: Most
challenging time, probably, I
would say, in my
career, was when I was
at USC as a college student.
And I would say it was
challenging because--
I went to USC.
And it's a school that is a
private school that students
are known to be a little bit
wealthier than the average.
And so I remember
there being times
where I didn't have a lot of
money, as a student athlete.
And you'll have $5,
and you're like, OK,
I'm going to order a
burrito and cut it in half,
and eat this half at
this point, and eat
this half at the other time.
There were times
where I remember that.
But I also remember
thinking, this
is not the way it's
always going to be.
But I really--
I wouldn't say I
enjoyed my struggle,
but I understood, when
I was in moments when
I didn't have that, it was
up to me to figure out ways
and to find a way to make it.
And it wasn't my mom's job--
once you get to college,
it's like, you've
got to figure it out.
You've got to figure out
how you're going to make it,
how you're going
to be successful.
And that's why I leaned so much
on my education and getting
my master's in
business, and just
really wanting to make
sure that I would never
be in that situation
again, financially.
NELSON BOYCE: That's right.
So it makes you appreciate these
times now a lot more, right?
LISA LESLIE: I'm so
blessed and thankful.
I love-- I just feel like we
have so many opportunities,
and you have to
keep taking them in.
Now, with social media and
just so much information
at our fingertips,
there's no reason
why people should not be
doing what they love to do,
their job that they love to--
I just happen to have five jobs.
I overdo it because of,
probably, my struggle.
But that's the compensation,
I think, I make.
NELSON BOYCE: Sure.
Nate, Chris?
Anything to contribute to that?
Most challenging time?
NATE ROBINSON: I
would say mine, it
didn't come until I got to the
league, to the NBA, really.
Because everything
had been hard for me,
from being a little guy.
But the hardest, I think,
when I got to the NBA was,
they wanted me to be
somebody that I wasn't.
And now, for me, that
was the hardest thing.
Because as a kid, I just
wanted to play basketball.
They were big on attitude and
the way you act, behavior.
And it was just hard for me.
I'm like, bro, I
just want to hoop.
I'm happy to be here.
Every game was like some
different superstar.
Vince Carter today?
Oh, word.
This is crazy.
So I was just
enjoying the moment.
I was enjoying the moment.
So my biggest
struggle was every day
it was like, all right,
Nate, you got to chill,
blah, blah, blah.
I'm like, you guys
are so worried
about everything
other than basketball.
And I didn't understand that.
So for me, that was the
hardest thing-- dealing
with being a starter,
and a player that you
play all the time, your whole
life, and coming to the league,
and you're just
coming off the bench.
Some games you don't play.
That was hard.
That was really hard for me.
But I enjoyed the ride.
I enjoyed the ups and downs.
The roller coaster was fun.
It was challenging.
And I had the best seat
in the house every night.
So I had to switch how I thought
the process of not playing.
I'm like, you know what?
I'm going to just embrace this.
I'm going to just
embrace me not playing.
And then I'm going to just
get on everybody's nerves,
asking for jerseys.
"Shaq, I need your jersey."
I was going to ask
every different person
for their stuff to keep me
right where I needed to be.
NELSON BOYCE: Absolutely.
Chris, what about you?
CHRIS WEBBER: Man, like
you just said, it's
been a journey, roller coaster.
And I think that for me,
it was my rookie year.
Because I was having
success, but at home,
people in my neighborhood
was going through things
that I couldn't help them with.
NELSON BOYCE: Back in Detroit.
CHRIS WEBBER: Yeah.
So it was a little bit
of survivor's remorse.
And you have to take
responsibility for the choices
that you make.
But some of my
friends at that time
made choices that, I'll
never see them again--
where they were killed,
or where they're in jail
for the rest of their life.
And so here it is.
You're reaching the dream,
and you're making it,
and you're loving it.
And when you're young,
you're sensitive.
You should be
sensitive all the time.
But you're young, and
you're wondering why you
and why not them.
And I just remember
the whole season,
I don't think I enjoyed
it as much because I
was living at home in my mind,
wanting to bring them with me
and wanting them to see all
of this stuff and things
I've never seen.
It's the most exciting
time in the world.
And you have people
that can't see it
and don't realize-- listen,
you can do whatever you want.
I just met somebody out
here that's doing great,
and they didn't even
finish second grade.
They just had the hard work.
And look, you can do it.
More stories and inspiration.
I wanted to take that to
them and let them see it.
But it was really hard, at that
time, to find that balance.
You want to save the world and
all your friends at one time.
And it takes a while.
So for me, that was
tough-- having success,
reaching a dream, and then
the kids that I dreamed with--
we veered off at a
point of a dream.
And it was like, dang, I wish
we could bring them with me.
So that was tough.
That was tough.
NELSON BOYCE: I hear that.
I can relate to that very well.
LISA LESLIE: That was
so well said, Chris.
NATE ROBINSON:
Yeah, that was dope.
CHRIS WEBBER: Thank you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LISA LESLIE: I like that.
NELSON BOYCE: Man, I've
got four or five questions
I wish I could ask you.
But we're going to
make sure that we
spend enough time letting some
of the folks in the audience
ask you some questions.
But before we go there, we're
going to do a little speed
round with you guys.
LISA LESLIE: Here you go.
You want to play games.
NELSON BOYCE: Yeah, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
LISA LESLIE: You know
we're competitive, now.
NELSON BOYCE: I told you.
I told you.
LISA LESLIE: And I got to win.
NELSON BOYCE: Well, this is
interesting, because all of you
win in this one.
So this is going to
be a function of--
NATE ROBINSON: But hold on--
NELSON BOYCE: Go ahead.
NATE ROBINSON: That's not
fair, because she always
wins the games we play.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
She's really good at
charades, everything.
CHRIS WEBBER: Seriously.
NELSON BOYCE: But this
is a this or that.
LISA LESLIE: Sorry.
Overachiever.
NELSON BOYCE: I'm going
to throw out two things,
and you're just going
to-- don't think about it.
Just choose one or the other.
CHRIS WEBBER: Got you.
LISA LESLIE: So
what is our answer?
The answer is one or the other?
NELSON BOYCE: It's
one or the other.
You'll see.
CHRIS WEBBER: She wants
the rules, everything.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what I'm saying?
NELSON BOYCE: It's
really not a competition.
NATE ROBINSON: Don't pass Go.
You can't collect $200.
It's that simple.
LISA LESLIE: I'm going
to try to calm down.
Fine, go.
NELSON BOYCE: And
I'm going to ask
everybody a different question.
LISA LESLIE: I'll
try to be regular.
NELSON BOYCE: All right?
So we're going to
start with Nate,
and we're going to go to
Chris, and we're going
to keep going back around.
All right?
LISA LESLIE: OK.
NELSON BOYCE: Dog or cat?
NATE ROBINSON: Dog.
Ar-ar.
NELSON BOYCE: Mac or PC?
LISA LESLIE: Mac.
CHRIS WEBBER: You
better say that.
You better say that.
NELSON BOYCE: Text or call?
CHRIS WEBBER: Call,
but I'm lying.
I'm text.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LISA LESLIE: He don't
answer his phone.
CHRIS WEBBER: But
I want to say call.
It's text.
LISA LESLIE: He don't
answer his phone.
NELSON BOYCE: Live or on demand?
NATE ROBINSON: Oh, man.
I'm going to say live.
NELSON BOYCE: All right.
Go to the store or order online?
LISA LESLIE: Go to--
CHRIS WEBBER: Mm,
think about it, now.
[LAUGHTER]
LISA LESLIE: Online.
I like both.
OK, online for sure.
NELSON BOYCE: Bacon or butter?
CHRIS WEBBER: Oh.
Butter.
NELSON BOYCE: Dunk or 3-pointer?
NATE ROBINSON: Duh.
[LAUGHTER]
Next question.
NELSON BOYCE: Player or coach?
LISA LESLIE: Player.
NELSON BOYCE: Hot or cold?
CHRIS WEBBER: Hot.
NELSON BOYCE: Vacation
or staycation?
NATE ROBINSON: I'm a homebody.
Staycation.
NELSON BOYCE: LeBron or Harden?
LISA LESLIE: LeBron.
[LAUGHTER]
NELSON BOYCE:
Beyonce or Rhianna?
CHRIS WEBBER: Oh!
[LAUGHTER]
Come on.
Oh, man!
Tough.
NATE ROBINSON: I'll
take that question.
I'll take that question.
CHRIS WEBBER: Oh, man, come on.
NATE ROBINSON: I'll
take it for him.
CHRIS WEBBER:
Beyonce and Rhianna.
[LAUGHTER]
NELSON BOYCE: Good enough.
NATE ROBINSON: Oh, for me?
NELSON BOYCE: No, I'm sorry.
Awake or asleep?
NATE ROBINSON: I
might say both, too.
Awake or asleep?
Oh, man.
CHRIS WEBBER: It's early
in the morning right now.
NATE ROBINSON: I know.
Awake.
NELSON BOYCE: Biggie or Tupac?
LISA LESLIE: Come on.
California love.
Tupac.
NELSON BOYCE: I know,
you California all day.
NATE ROBINSON: I'm about
to say, [INAUDIBLE]..
NELSON BOYCE: Chris,
Han Solo or Chewie?
CHRIS WEBBER: Oh.
Yeah.
When Han Solo got frozen
in "Empire Strikes Back"
back in the day?
I got to go Han Solo.
NELSON BOYCE: There it is.
CHRIS WEBBER: I've
got to go Han Solo.
NELSON BOYCE: "The
Godfather" or "Scarface"?
NATE ROBINSON: Oh.
I'm going to say
"Scarface" for me.
I grew up on that.
NELSON BOYCE: Pac-Man
or Ms. Pac-Man?
LISA LESLIE: Ms. Pac-Man.
NELSON BOYCE: Shoes or sneakers?
CHRIS WEBBER:
Sneakers all day long.
Sneakers.
NELSON BOYCE: And this
is for all three of you.
Google or Bing?
[LAUGHTER]
LISA LESLIE: Google
me, #google me.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NELSON BOYCE: Let's open
it up to the audience.
We've got a
microphone over here.
Oh, you all can't be shy.
Thank you.
NATE ROBINSON: Yeah, I was
about to say, come on now.
We up here.
NELSON BOYCE: I've got
more questions I can ask.
I don;t want to hog.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks so much for coming.
This is pretty much
a dream come true.
It's a question for all of you.
Who was your favorite person
to play against and why?
LISA LESLIE: To play against?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Or to play with.
Either way.
CHRIS WEBBER: To
play against, for me,
I would have to say
it was Michael Jordan.
One time, we were playing
him in the playoffs.
He had 54 points, maybe--
something like that.
And I looked at
Juwan, my teammate.
And in front of Jordan,
we would work out,
we would always, like, "Oh,
he sold his soul to the devil.
He's not supposed to
be making these shots."
And I was trying to get him off.
And I really thought he sold--
like, he made stuff, man,
that is not humanly possible.
So it was great trying
to take him down,
knowing that there
probably wasn't a chance
that you were going to do it.
So I say the great
Michael Jordan.
LISA LESLIE: Yeah.
I think I would
say Lauren Jackson.
I enjoyed playing against
her, because she was really
a tough player to
guard and to stop.
And we had so many battles.
And she's the real deal.
Between her 3-point shot
and her ability to score
inside was the most
challenging to stop their pick
and roll and stop her inside.
And she could block my
shot-- only on one side.
I had to finally
figure that out.
I'm like, how did
she get in my shot?
So I had to go left.
But she was the most
challenging player,
I think, I played against.
NATE ROBINSON: For me, it
would probably Iverson.
Because I was a
little guy growing up
watching another little guy
change the whole league.
You've got to understand
what he brought to the game.
He made it OK for
people to be themselves.
And then for me, I hit a
game-winning shot over him.
Changed my life forever.
Facts.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WEBBER: Facts!
LISA LESLIE: Plugged.
NELSON BOYCE: Thank you.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you all for coming.
Huge fan.
I can think of highlights
of many of you, the things
that you all have done.
But I'm just interested
in what's your best
highlight of yourself?
NATE ROBINSON: Oh, wow.
LISA LESLIE: Best highlight.
CHRIS WEBBER: I don't
know if I've been
asked that question before.
AUDIENCE: I can help.
[LAUGHTER]
NATE ROBINSON: I would say,
for me, my best highlight,
would say my children.
More so than basketball,
they're a part of me.
I'm trying to shape
them to be the best
people they can be growing up--
sports, education wise, and
just living life for the fullest
and what it is.
So for me, it would be
my children, for sure.
LISA LESLIE: That was
such a great answer.
Well, I thought basketball
initially, when you asked.
So basketball, just in
terms of highlights--
it's one thing to represent
my city and state,
to play it in Los Angeles
for the Los Angeles
Sparks my whole career.
But to have
represented our country
is definitely the
highlight for me--
to put on the red,
white, and blue.
And I know we weren't
in the service,
but it feels like you're
going to war when you
play against other countries.
And to come out on top--
just a little back story.
Our USA team actually lost to--
we lost in a world
championship to Brazil.
And as you know, Brazil,
like even in soccer,
they're very animated.
They cheer.
So they were so
animated-- and this
is the problem-- they put us
on the same bus to the game
and back.
NATE ROBINSON: Oh, wow.
LISA LESLIE: Right.
Yeah, that part.
CHRIS WEBBER: Who does that?
[LAUGHTER]
Who does that?
LISA LESLIE: So on
the way back home--
NATE ROBINSON: What?
LISA LESLIE: --Team
USA-- and it was
one of the first times I
got to the national team.
So I was one of the younger
players at that time.
They had made a bet
with their coach
that if they beat Team USA,
which is a really big deal,
that they could shave his head.
Yeah.
So they shaved his
head on the bus,
while we rode back with them.
So that level of disrespect--
I vowed we would never lose.
Not only to Brazil,
but we would never--
because we ended up with a
bronze medal for the world
championship, which is--
I don't even know
where that medal
is, if I accepted that or not.
Never talk about it.
But the highlight, then, is to
go on and win four gold medals.
I also have two gold
world championship medals
that nobody ever talks about.
But to go on and win gold
for the rest of my career
wearing the red, white, and
blue is the highlight for me.
Go USA, right?
CHRIS WEBBER: Go USA.
[APPLAUSE]
That's a hard story to beat.
That would have been--
we'd have had beef.
LISA LESLIE: Oh, it was awful.
CHRIS WEBBER: I would have taken
the clippers out of his hand,
thrown them out the window,
or something like that.
It would have been
a fight on the bus.
LISA LESLIE: Terrible.
CHRIS WEBBER: Wow.
I'd have to start with,
maybe, playing in college.
Playing with the group of guys,
the fab five at that time.
And the reason why--
Nate talks about his mentality.
And if you get to
know Nate, you know
he's still that 10-year-old.
He's still a beast when it comes
to sports and his mentality.
But to be at that age, I
think all you guys understand,
or maybe you're in that space
now, to be free mentally,
to know that the world is
against you and to embrace it
and to take it on, but
not be bitter enough
where you've experienced
a thing and it turns sad.
It's more so like an embracing
of taking on the world.
And playing with those
guys was just so much fun,
because we were
on the same page.
We all were dumb,
young, and naive,
and believed we could do it all.
And that's a great place to be
when you work hard, you know?
And so I would just say being
with those guys every day,
having them affect my
life and who I was,
and building those
true friendships.
And then the highlights,
dunking on people, too,
with those guys.
That was a lot of fun.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS WEBBER: Thank you.
LISA LESLIE: Thank you.
NELSON BOYCE: Speaking
of dunking, Lisa,
I'm surprised you
didn't say the dunk.
LISA LESLIE: Yeah.
That's other
people's highlights.
NELSON BOYCE: Yeah.
That's true.
[LAUGHTER]
True, indeed.
LISA LESLIE: That's not
the highlight of my career.
NELSON BOYCE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys for
coming and stopping by here.
So fast forward 50 years
from now, 100 years from now.
If you could have one game that
your great-great-grandchildren
could watch of yourself, which
game would you pick, and why?
NATE ROBINSON: Oh, wow.
CHRIS WEBBER: Wow.
LISA LESLIE: That
was so deep, man.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS WEBBER: I've never
been asked these before.
NELSON BOYCE: Welcome to Google.
LISA LESLIE: I would
say that I have not
a lot of games in
my whole career
where I have triple-double,
but I do have one in particular
where I had 10 blocks.
And I won Defensive
Player of the Year.
I loved playing defense.
It was playing both ends
of the court, of course.
And people know
about the scoring.
But I really love defense.
And so I had one game
where I had 10 blocks.
And for my son and daughter,
who plays sports and plays
basketball, I would like
for them to see that game.
Because I think that
game is just so complete,
whether it was scoring or
rebounding and blocking shots.
But the defensive effort--
and it was a championships,
so that was really important.
But, yeah, 10 blocks is--
that's pretty
good, right, Chris?
For real.
CHRIS WEBBER: That's great.
No, I'm like, damn!
[LAUGHTER]
I'm like damn, shawty.
LISA LESLIE: Get
that out of here!
Yeah.
That game was pretty cool.
CHRIS WEBBER: 50,
100 years from now.
We want our kids
to see, you said?
AUDIENCE: Great grandkids.
CHRIS WEBBER: Great grandkids.
AUDIENCE: Great-great
grandkids, whatever.
CHRIS WEBBER: I would say--
I think I had 28 points
and maybe 13 rebounds.
But it was in a game I called a
timeout at the end of the game.
And I would show
them that, because I
would want them to
know you're going
to go through
things in your life
even when you did your
best and you won't win--
maybe you'll make a
mistake, maybe you'll lose.
But look how good
of a game it was.
Look how it turned
out at the end.
And hopefully they
would see, wow,
that was a messed up moment.
Hopefully they would
ask the question,
what did he do after that?
And so hopefully,
that would teach
them to have a great
game, do your thing,
kill it, be yourself.
But if you run into a big
speed bump, go ahead and cry.
Get it out of your system.
Get around some people
that love and support you,
forget it, and keep moving.
Even the best games-- like Lisa
talked about her 10 blocks.
I bet it's fun for her
to think about it now,
because when she
was a player, she
was so competitive, she didn't
think about her best games
then, because she
could always know,
I could get 11
blocks or 12 blocks.
And so hopefully through
that, they would see,
there was a bad man.
He made a mistake.
And look at that and then
wonder how you get through it.
And hopefully that would
inspire them to never worry
about their worst
moments, even in the best
times of their lives.
NATE ROBINSON: Yeah, I'm
going to say for me, when
I played with the Knicks,
I had a coach named
Mike D'Antoni who sat me down.
He didn't play me
for a whole month.
I'll never forget this.
He sat me down
for a whole month,
didn't give me a
reason or nothing.
And I remember one New
Year's, I called my mom.
I'm like, Mom, I
need you to come.
I need somebody
there with me, just
to see a familiar face,
somebody that I love.
And my mom's my best friend.
So I flew her to Atlanta
and I took her to dinner.
We went and ate.
And I ran into the coach.
I ran into an
Atlanta Hawks coach.
And he was like, "You
playing tomorrow?"
I was like, no, I haven't
been playing for, like,
a whole month.
It was like 14 games he sat me.
And he ended up putting me
in the game the next day.
And I ended up having,
like, 41 points.
We won the game--
went to overtime.
And the whole time, I can hear
my mom cheering so loud up
there.
[LAUGHTER]
Over everybody.
"That's right,
Nate [INAUDIBLE]!"!"
She was going hard.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WEBBER: She called
you by your full first name!
NATE ROBINSON: Yeah.
I'm like, yeah,
that's what moms do.
As a kid, you hear
that reassurance
that mom is there for me.
So I just played
that game for her.
And it changed my life.
Because it was a big story--
"SportsCenter," a coach
sent you down for a month.
I worked out hard before the
game-- ran bleachers, still
did my work out.
So that would be something
that I would love
for my grandchildren to know.
Even through-- you
go through adversity.
You just stay ready
no matter what.
Because when your
number's called--
I could have easily
just not been ready
and just said
"whatever," or even told
him, no, I don't want to go in.
I just said, I'm going to
take full advantage of this.
I'm going to see
where it gets me.
I said, God, just don't
let me make the first shot,
because it's a wrap.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll make this first one
after sitting down a month?
So for me, that would
be part of the game,
coming in, helping my team.
And we won, too.
That was a big deal.
And all my teammates
supported me.
They showed me a lot of love.
It was pretty awesome.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys.
CHRIS WEBBER: Thank you.
NELSON BOYCE: We're going
to take one last question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, y'all.
This is awesome.
LISA LESLIE: Hi.
CHRIS WEBBER: How you doing?
AUDIENCE: So it looks
like "Uncle Drew"
is a movie about old school guys
teaching the youngings what's
up, right?
So when you were
young, what's a bit
of advice that you received
from somebody older, wiser, that
helped you in your
success in life?
CHRIS WEBBER: With me,
the first day of practice,
I was drafted by Golden State.
And I was so excited
to meet Chris Mullin.
So he's one of the best
shooters I've ever seen.
New Yorker, talked like this--
""[INAUDIBLE] Webb,
come over here."
I can't understand him.
I'm excited.
And I wanted to
just be around him.
I bought a place where he lived.
I wanted the car that he had.
I wanted to be around him.
And the craziest thing
is, more than shooting,
more than anything else,
after practice, he brought me
into the training room.
And he said, "This is what
I want to do every day."
It was a hot tub and a cold tub.
He said, "I want you to go two
minutes in the hot tub, two
minutes in the cold tub,
two minutes in the hot tub."
I'm like, come on.
You don't need to stretch
when you're young.
You can do everything.
And then I found myself
doing that every game.
And through all the injuries,
I found myself, 15 years later,
doing that-- what he told me.
So he really taught me how
to take care of my body
with nutrition.
He was at the end of his career.
And telling me all that
in the beginning really
helped me at least
focus my mind and be
ready to listen to my body and
stay prepared the whole time.
And I think he had
a big influence
on how I take care of my body,
how I prepared in the summer.
Because he was relentless
in his training.
And I think that was
the basis for having
a pretty good career for me.
LISA LESLIE: For me,
as a kid, I think
my mom was my
biggest inspiration,
and she shared a lot
of things with me.
Being a single parent
raising three girls,
and then just being so tall.
I've been tall all my life.
My second grade teacher
called home and was
like, "Do you realize
Lisa's taller than me
and the rest of the children?"
And my mom's like, "Yeah,
well, what's the problem?"
My mom's like, "I'm 6'2".
Her dad's 6'4".
And she said, "Oh, OK,
well, excuse the call."
So being this tall all my life,
having my mom be so positive
about my posture, and
sitting up straight,
and that some people
grow on the inside
and some people grow
on the outside--
and our family's been
blessed enough to do both,
so don't be ashamed
of being tall.
And you have to stand up tall.
And there was a lot of
that-- when you're tall
and people ask you every single
day, "Do you play basketball?"
and you're like, no.
Why do you--
I don't understand
the association
with my height and basketball.
So for me, just
through grade school,
it was always this constant
barrage of questions and people
talking about my height.
And it was really annoying.
When you're a kid, you don't
really get the whole comments
and stuff.
So my mom was always
constantly dropping
in these seeds of
building me up and making
me feel confident and
comfortable in my own skin.
And I think that the
biggest takeaways
that she would tell
us was small things,
like "you can't receive
anything with a closed fist,
so always have an open hand
in helping other people."
"We're all God's children."
Just, really, a voice of
love and positivity that,
eventually, my
sister and I-- we're
always like, we're
our mother's daughter.
Because all we do
is, if somebody says,
"Oh my god, this
headache is killing me"--
"No, don't say that, because
it's not killing you.
You just have a
headache this moment,
but you're going to be better."
And then--
[LAUGHTER]
--everything is this whole
positive affirmation.
But I love it.
And the other thing she would
tell us was the seven Ps.
The seven Ps are Proper Prior
Preparation Prevents Piss-Poor
Performance.
So the seven Ps was
simply, whatever
you want to do, whatever
you want to get out of life,
you've got to do it.
You've got to work hard.
But you're got to get
out of it whatever
effort you put into it.
So if you're going to do
it, what did your mom say?
Do it right or
don't do it at all,
because you're going to go back
and do it anyway, in our house.
So it was all of these
positive affirmations
that my mom kept giving my
sisters and I that I felt
helped mold me into
being able to accept--
God knows I didn't know I
was going to get to 6'5".
This is ridiculous.
I'm like, Lord--
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WEBBER: Stop.
LISA LESLIE: Stop, yeah.
Like, what are we doing here?
Because six foot was like--
six foot in the sixth grade.
I know.
I know, right?
CHRIS WEBBER: What?
You were taller than
me in sixth grade.
LISA LESLIE: Sixth grade.
I was six foot.
Thank god my teacher was 6'2".
And this other Wonderboy,
Samuel, he was 6 foot.
So I'm like, perfect.
And the tallest people got
to be the line leaders.
I was so excited.
Because it's usually the
tallest are in the back.
You guys don't feel
me, but listen.
[LAUGHTER]
When you're tall, this
is a struggle, here.
NATE ROBINSON: Those are
tall people problems.
LISA LESLIE: Tall people
problems, exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
Exactly.
You were always the
line leader, right?
NATE ROBINSON: Yeah.
LISA LESLIE: Yeah.
It's not right.
Who made up that rule?
So anyway, so all
of that was just,
I feel like my mom being so
positive and knowing ahead,
having the [INAUDIBLE]----
because her growing up
in the '60s, being tall was
just like, what are you doing?
Like, who told you could grow?
We're going to have to get
shoeboxes for your shoes.
It was a negative thing.
And parents and people
made negative comments
about tall women.
So I'm thankful that
my mom gave me all
of that positive affirmations.
And for all the tall
women in the room,
feel good, represent,
keep your head up high.
We are just Queens
amongst the people.
[LAUGHTER]
NATE ROBINSON: Well, I don't
got tall people problems.
[LAUGHTER]
LISA LESLIE: What's the
other end of the spectrum?
NATE ROBINSON: So mine will
come from my mother, as well.
She really wasn't that vocal.
She led by just showing.
Three jobs, took care of
three kids all on our own.
And I just watched her
hustle and grind every day.
And she smiled doing it.
So my mother been working
for Boeing for like 30 years.
LISA LESLIE: She's just
so cute, oh my god.
NATE ROBINSON: She's been
a janitor for 30 years.
And she's never complained
a day in her life.
And she just goes.
So I think that's where I get
my hunger and drive from, is
from her, for sure.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
LISA LESLIE: Thank you.
NELSON BOYCE: Ladies
and gentlemen--
[APPLAUSE]
--Chris Webber, Lisa
Leslie, Nate Robinson.
[APPLAUSE]